karim ya ampliar es la nueva secretaria
de prensa de la casa blanca y se
convierte en la primera mujer afro y
abiertamente lesbiana en ocupar ese
puesto precisamente en una conferencia
de prensa muy conmovedora junto a james
aquí a quien relevará en el cargo dio
sus primeras declaraciones moment
es un momento histórico entiendo lo
importante que esto es para las
diferentes comunidades allá afuera a las
cuales se ha apoyado en el transcurso de
mi carrera
así que es un honor y un privilegio
estar aquí parada
javier actualmente la subsecretaria de
prensa de la casa blanca y asumirá su
cargo una vez aquí lo abandone a media
de sumario
las minorías importan y ella dará voz a
todos ellos
ha mostrado que el esfuerzo y soñar en
grande importa así que eso hay que
celebrarlo esta boleta hija de haitianos
se ha desempeñado como analista política
pues jefa de gabinete de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris durante su
campaña presidencial en el 2020 también
participó en las campañas del ex
presidente barack obama en el 2008 y
2012 y vocera de la organización
progresista muy kong o hereje en mayo
fue la segunda mujer negra en la
historia de eeuu en brindar una rueda de
prensa diaria desde la casa blanca
igualmente ha sido parte del equipo del
presidente by the end desde que asumió
el cargo la presidencia de joe biden ha
venido impulsando cambios estructurales
dando lugar a un sector de la población
que ha sido históricamente marginado en
el país como son los afroamericanos
primero el anuncio de cuentan yo y brown
tax o como la primera mujer negra corte
suprema y ahora el nombramiento de karen
jean pierre